hello my name is adolfo garcia
and i'm going to be talking to you today
about some of our work on
sars chronovirus 2 biology with an
emphasis
in our search for new antivirals
i'm professor of the department of
microbiology and director of the global
health and emerging pathos institute at
the acken school of medicine at mount
sinai
and what you are seeing here for the
beginning of my presentation
these are cells that are infected with
such chronovirus ii
they have been stained and there is one
strain cell with antibodies
n of sars chronovirus so you see the
infected cell
and uh with an antibody against uh in
green against ac2
you see uh the expression of ac2 and
these are
veto cells it's any mistake by mustafa
and lisa uh here at mount sinai
now i start my presentation with an
influenza slide and the reason is
because most of my
work has been centered on influenza but
also um what uh what my lab is doing
right now in terms of
sars chronovirus 2 has to do uh in part
with what we learned from working with
influenza
so influenza is also a respiratory virus
like sarcoma virus ii
it has also an envelope and a receptor
binding
protein with this case the hemoglotinin
and it's different from the sarcomeres
too because
of the proteins are obviously
antigenically different
receptor is different and the genetic
material is
rna but in the case of influenza is a
segmented rna virus
with eight negative strand rna-var
segments while
sas coronavirus ii is a coronavirus and
it's a positive strand or any virus with
a single rna segment
now in the case of influenza each of the
eight
rna segments encodes for one or two
proteins
and some of them are structural as
depicted here in the scheme of the virus
and some of them are non-structural
as also depicted here in this slide
now if we go to uh sars chronovirus 2
this is a coronavirus so this is now a
single segmented rna virus with an rna
genome that is positive strand meaning
that
it's going to be used as messenger rna
when it's been delivered inside the cell
and it's going to encode right away from
the ribosomes
the viral proteins which is different
from the negative strata rna virus like
influenza
uh now uh in is an enveloped virus like
influenza and the main
uh the major glycoprotein that is uh
outside of the virion is the spike
protein which is the target for
neutralizing antibodies
uh but it has also another minor
components of the envelope like the e
protein
and the m protein and now inside uh
of this envelope there is the rna
segment uh
which is a unique rna molecule
that is covered with a viral protein
that is the end protein so when this
uh rna molecule is delivered inside an
infected cell it's been used as
messenger rna
and it's been encoded all the viral
proteins uh
now the first messenger rna that encode
that is
is the genome and codes for a big
polyprotein called or1an or 1b
that this cliff into total of 16
different
non-structural proteins and sp1 2 till
and sp16
an addition from the genome uh during
replication you gene
the virus generates sub genomic rna that
gives a
another messenger rnas that now encode
for the
structural proteins s e m and n
as well as for accessory factors like
the
six r3a a seven b eight and b nine c
and ten and then if you compare
different coronaviruses
um they they have more or less
some conserved areas but the ones that
are less conserved
of the one for these accessory factors
they are very unique
and distinguish different coronaviruses
so the
the uh accessory factors of sars
chronovirus ii
um they are also very unique some of
them
are similar to the ones of the search
coronavirus the first
stars that we got that we got a while
ago
but some of them are very unique and
only found in the susquehanna virus too
now getting back to influenza this is
light yes it's just to illustrate that
the virus
requires enters inside the cell to enter
the studies
in order to replicate make viral
proteins and make new variants
now during this process the virus has
very a small amount of genetic material
only 18s in the case of influenza
but the virus diagonal is going to need
to use
host factors that are required for the
replication and trafficking
of the viral proteins and assembly of
the new variants
and in addition is gonna encounter
antibiotic factors that are produced by
the cell that
somehow sense that it's been infected
and it's gonna try to
um prevent this infection
now in order to find these required host
factors and
to avoid the activity of these antiviral
factors
there are proteins that have been
encoded by the virus need
to interact either functionally or
physically with these required host
factors
to help them in replication or with
these antiviral factors to prevent the
antiviral activity
and is in this interplay between
interaction between the vowel
components and the host components but
at the end it gives you a productive
infection or not depending on how these
interactions take place
you're going to get the virus taking
over the cell and making copies of
itself or you're going to get the cell
being able to avoid and prevent viral
infection
now with coronaviruses this is very
similar is that that
the replication is a little bit
different and these viruses don't use
the nucleus like it's the case of
influenza
but with the en test through a
receptor-mediated entry
in this case in the case of sarcoma
virus ii is the
human ac2 protein then
is gonna deliver the rna inside the
cytoplasma and
it's going to make some genomic rnas and
as i mentioned for the long messenger
rnase you get
this big polyprotein that encodes the
replicase
and all of the nsps and from the others
you get these other type of proteins
including the spike and some of the orbs
in this case
the nomenclature for these proteins is
based in the mouse hepatitis virus but
it's a similar replication cycle for
susquehanna virus too
and at one moment um this virus like the
influenza
needs to interact with host factors that
are required for helping in the
replication
and it needs also to deal with
antibiotic factors and again like
influenza
it's gonna be the interplay between the
vowel components and the
and the host factors but it's going to
at the end
give a productive infection more
virulence being made
or an antiviral state of the cell
preventing the environment application
now one one uh pro one of the questions
that my
my lab has been trying to understand in
terms of viruses and special aberrant
virus and as i mentioned before
mainly with influenza is which host
factors are important for virus
replication and pathogenesis
what are these required host factors
that the virus needs to use and what are
the scientific factors that the virus
needs to avoid
and that at the end determine what is
the outcome of our replication
in order to answer that for influenza we
have a large
program that is funded by niid in the
form of a u19 grant that we call
fluoromix
these are many of the people that are
involved in this
program with the emails of the people
and it has an intercollaboration between
multiple institutions
including my lab how many people
and what we're trying to do is we try to
use assistance biology
type of approach to understand the host
factors that are important for virus
application and pathogenesis
with the idea of if we know these
factors we may also know
either way how we can inhibit
viral replication by inhibiting the host
factors that are required for viral
replication
or by enhancing the activity of
antibiotic factors
that are trying to prevent the
replication now here is just one example
of the type of
studies that we do in this program here
in yellow in circles are the different
proteins of
influenza you see mp and ep
and aha these are different proteins of
influenza and then they're connected
through lines
to horse factors and these are host
factors that we identified
in collaboration with nevan krogan as
host factors that interact with these
vowel proteins so there is
many host factors that interact with the
fire proteins but
there is a total of 30 000 genes and
this is just a subset now of the genes
of the proteins of the host that now we
have identified as interacting
with the viral proteins and we
hypothesized that these
proteins that are able to interact host
proteins that are able to interact with
viral proteins
are going to be important for viral
replication but in addition we have here
more information not just the protein
horse proteins that interact with a
single
influenza virus protein which is each of
the single influenza vs proteins but we
have
also according to the this
color code factors that if you silence
them
so if you eliminate the expression from
the host cell
are going to result in an impact in
viral replication
and depending on the color there are
factors that have been identified by
multiple labs or by a signal lab
so what we have here now is a collection
of host factors that have
multiple evidence that they participate
in viral replication either because they
interact with viral protein or because
when you eliminate this factor from the
host cell
you make an impact in viral application
via replication goes up
or goes down and there is as an example
there are two
host factors that are here indicated
sec-61
and top one that are included among this
map
and they are known inhibitors of these
factors
ct8 will inhibit 6x61
come to testing will inhibit top one and
we have
used these inhibitors to find that they
are
able to prevent influenza virus
replication
are they able to prevent influenza virus
disease in animal model
and i include here two of the papers
where we have described this thing
so we we are using this map in order to
find out
novel uh inhibitors of influenza virus
that may be able to use in the clinic so
we have been working on that for several
years and then
sars chronovirus came
um the pandemic and then we have
basically
used the same resources that they were
using for influenza
and try to apply it for the search of
antivirals against
covet 19 against saskrnavarus ii
and that it has been again a
collaboration between multiple people
i will mention some of the main people
that have been involved in this
collaboration but there are some people
that i will not mention that i have also
participated
now how we are looking for a therapy and
is not only us but many people
um for sales chronovirus ii
now we know already that there are some
compounds that have been approved for
emergency use
ramdesavir is an inhibitor of the
rna-dependent rna polymerase of the
virus
plasma from comparison individuals they
have antibodies that are able to prevent
by binding to the spike
replication of the virus binding of the
virus to the receptor
dexamethasone is a is an immunomodulator
a cinema suppressor
that reduced the exacerbated immune
response that happened in some cases
of civil infection and all of these
factors have been shown to have
some efficacy some ability to ameliorate
disease but this is not happening
doesn't happen in
all the patients and they are also not
completely effective 100 effective so we
still need
some new antivirals and in order to do
that the the strategy that we're using
we call it drug repurposing and it's not
only us that we're doing that
but there are many people that are also
doing that what is track repurposing
this is using the already existing drugs
that have been used in the clinic
in humans so we know some about
what is the effect the impact of these
drugs what are the site
adverse events uh what are the targets
for what indications have been used
and what we take is this list of drugs
and then based on prediction based on
omics studies
we make the hypothesis of which of these
tracks are going to likely to make an
impact in vowel replication
and i will show you the type of mix
studies and how we do these predictions
you know
in a moment and now once that we make
these predictions then we test these
tracks for inhibition of replication in
tissue culture
and then if some of them are able to
inhibit the viral replication
then these ones we are moving it into
animal models and
if they are working well in animal
models we hopefully will be able to be
in clinical studies
but in some instances actually some of
the tracks that we have found
are already in clinical studies for sas
carnivorous too
the advantage of doing this drug
repurposing is that
these drugs are known already what is
the dose that is tolerated in humans and
therefore one can
rapidly deploy in order to make clinical
trials even
sometimes before you know what is the
impact in animal models
so this accelerate a lot the possibility
of drug development
so the question here is can we identify
compounds that inhibit host factors
involving such chronovirus to
replication among non-human drugs
so first how we identify these host
factors involved in such scrutiny virus
to replication so again we are using
genomics
approach and this is one of the ways how
we do it
this is a collaboration with nevan
program that is here depicted
in this picture
as the source of the host genes
around 20 000 genes that we humans uh
express and then here the idea is
sars chronovirus juice has a total of 29
encoded proteins
and evan krogan has expressed each one
individually
in cells human cells which have all
these 20 000 proteins
put the pelleted down and then
determined by mass spectrometry
what type of horse proteins interact
with these
viral proteins and doing that you create
this map that is here in the middle
which is called a virus host interactome
in which
in red circles they are depicted
each of the 29 proteins of such
chronovirus two
and then uh with lines they are
indicated the host protists that have
been identified as interacting with this
one
with the idea again that if they
interact with viral protein
probably they are doing something during
bulb replication it's been co-opted by
the bowel protein
so in total he identified a total of 332
protein protein interactions
now interesting thing is that if you
look to these proteins these horse
proteins
there are some factors that are
draggable and they are non-drugs
that are targeting these factors that
have been used at one moment
in the clinic or they have been using
actually for some
specific uh indications in humans
so here i come kevin shocket and brian
soitet
which are our also two collaborators
that are
chemical bioinformaticians that have
looked to this map
of protein protein interactions and then
identified them on the host factors that
interact with viral proteins
are drugs that are targeted specifically
one of these host factors which is what
is included here in this very busy slide
and then they identify the total of 97
drugs
and then in our lab chris white with the
help of lisa meorin and also elena
moreno
have been testing these drugs for
ability to inhibit valve replication
and we have some hits meaning that we
have some inhibitors of our replications
that were identified
so how we test this these inhibitors of
our replication for that we developed
a medium throughput assay to uh look for
inhibitors of our replication in vitro
we use in the beginning veto6 cells
which they are
support very well viral replication and
we sit them into 96 well plates
and then after um
system two hours before we infect them
we treat the cells with a drug
and one of the drugs that is known to
interact with one of these host factors
and different dilutions of this drug
then two hours later we have sars
konavirus2 and we use
an amount of infectious viruses that
will infect
approximately around uh 10
of the cells a little bit less than 10
we collaborate with a group in paris
that are performing similar
studies just to compare data
and then we let the virus replicate for
48 hours
and then finishing this 48 hours we fix
the cells
we inactivate the virus we take this out
of the bsl3 till now we do this
experiments in bsl3 because it has an
infectious
chronovirus2 and then we determine the
extent of our replication so
if we have an inhibitor of our
replication the virus will have
replicated less
now how we look for valve replication um
in our lab in new york
uh we use two assays the first one is
the the rapid assay in which we take the
cells that have been fixed and we stain
with an antibody against
one of the sars proteins so if there is
no inhibition of our replication
approximately
80 percent of the cells have been
infected after these 48 hours
in contact of cells and viruses but if
there is an inhibitor of our replication
there is less cells that will be
infected
uh in addition the ones that they are
giving the heat we take the supernatant
from these cells and when we determine
the amount of virus that have been
produced in the supernatant as tissue
cultural infections those 50s
and again if we have an inhibitor of our
replication then you will get
also less viruses in addition we conduct
one more assay which is not shown in
here
which is a cytotoxicity assay of the
compound
in the absence of virus in the presence
of cells so making sure that we get
inhibition of our replication
is not because the compound is killing
the cells and then therefore the cells
cannot support viral replication
is because the compound has direct
antiviral activity
and our collaborators are distribute of
paris of paris in france olivier marco
and christophe
they conduct very similar um acid steps
that instead of using a
staining against mp for determining the
amount of infection
they use a quantitative rt pcr to
quantify viral genomes that are being
replicated in the presence or absence of
the inhibitor
and if they are inhibiting they perform
black assays
to find the amount of viruses that are
being present in the supernatural
and this by the way how black assay
looks like for this virus this
what you see here are veto cells
monologues that have been infected
different dilutions with sars konavirus
ii
and then after 48 hours
if there is a lot of viruses then the
cells are being killed and therefore
if you stain the monolayer you will not
see a blue color
and as you go in uh diluting the virus
then you are starting to see these holes
that have been made in the monolayer
these holes have been made by one virus
particle that infects first the cell in
the in the center of the hole and then
propagates to the next one
and killing them and that's how we can
titrate efficiently
um the standoff of replication of the
virus in the supernatant of these
cells okay so first i'm going to
show you um uh how rendezvous which is a
drug that is already approved
inhibits valve replication in this asset
so what we have is
in all of these assets of inhibition of
our replication we do you perform
triplicates
in which a particular drug is used at
the total of six different
concentrations
from around 10 microns the form
around 10 micromolar going down to
nanomolar concentrations with six
different dilutions
and then what you can see is that in the
discontinuous line
you see the cytotoxicity of the drug at
different concentrations which in the
case of rendezvous is not cytotoxic
the cells tolerate well predictably
that's good news
and in the solid line you see extent of
viral replication and what you can see
is that
as you use increased concentrations of
rendessive you are inhibiting viral
replication
with the ones that are high levels of of
from decivil
you don't detect uh infected cells and
lower levels of
rheumatism you detect the same
percentage of infected cells that in the
absence of regressivity
and this allow us to calculate what we
call ic90 which is
a um inhibitory concentration
90 in which the compound is inhibiting
90
of our replication which in the case of
rendezvous and forbidden cells
is 1.5 micromolar and also what is the
selective index which is
uh uh what uh hum
how close is this inhibitory
concentration to
a cytotoxicity which in the case of
density is more than 26 so it's a drug
that can be used
for inhibition of our replication now
not everything that inhibits viral
replication in vitro is going to work in
vivo
but things some of the things that
inhibit our application in vitro also
going to work in vivo and these are the
ones
this is the first asset that we do to
see whether we get an inhibitor
now uh you use the same assay not in
viral cells which are monkey cells
for vendetta in human cells and for that
we need to is
this human cell we need to express ac2
because that's not express ac2
to allow the virus to replicate so these
are done now in 283 t cells ac2
now actually the ic90 different density
will go from one micromolar into 24
nanomolar
which is more characteristic of what is
the effective dose of redistributing
humans
the reason why is more effective in
human cells from this view that that
inferior cells because rendezvous is a
protract
that needs to be transformed into the
real drug once that you give it
and the enzymes that transfer that
transform the protract into drug
they are more active in human cells than
in monkey cells like viral cells and
that's the reason
why rendezvous is more active in human
cells and that's also the reason
why we normally use more than one cell
type in order to make sure that an
inhibitor
is not only cell type specific and also
works in human cells
so now we have taken all these compounds
that were predicted to uh
inhibit one of these host factors and we
conducted all these antiviral assays
here is an example of some that are the
ones that we've been done
um we have now more than 400 tags not
only coming from this study but also
coming from another studies
and we have identified some that seems
to be very important in terms of
inhibition of our replication
not all of them were able to inhibit our
replication by some of them were very
important
now in the first study that we did which
was based in the interaction we found 10
agents
that so it could effect us in killing
viruses
um they we get the same results as
the results that they get with the same
drugs in the institute's bastard of
paris
and among these tracks we found two
different type of compounds
and compounds that are inhibiting
translation of proteins which is sort of
typhin
and ternatin4 and some compounds that
are modulators of the activity of the
sigma receptors sigmar 1 or sigma 2
which corresponds to a large different
type of compounds with different
chemical structures
with different indications but all of
them they have in common
that they target the sigma receptor
factors
and they have antibiotic activity
against chronovirus too
so these are the tracks that compounds
that bind inhibit sigma r1 and sigma 2.
the reason why we concentrate in these
drugs is because we found two proteins
of the virus that interacts with these
receptors of 9c and an sp6
and here are some examples of these
tracks and how they work
some work better than others
interestingly hydroxychloroquine which
is one of the ones that has been um
giving a lot of attention as potential
inhibitor is a drug that inhibits fire
replication in vitro
and is a drug that also targets sigma
receptors
but among all of these tracks we have
some antihistamines antipsychotics
anti-malarials
um some hormones some anti-anxiety
drugs some preclinical drugs a monologue
distracts one of the ones that is more
potent is this pb22 which is here in the
upper right corner which has a better
uh inhibitory activity than the
hydroxychloroquine
and therefore we think that can be
better than hydroxychloroquine for
inhibiting of our replication but that's
something that we still need to
look into animal models
so one of the advantages of using pb22
versus chloroquine or hydroxychloroquine
is that if you look for binding of these
compounds to the sigma receptors and to
another clause receptor which is a
receptor that is found in the heart
erg and that is believed that this gives
some of the toxicity of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
both hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
bind quite efficiently
to the human earth's receptor
meaning that it's likely that they have
some cardiovascular toxicity
and they bind more poorly to the sigma
receptors however pv22
binds poorly to the human edge
erg so it's likely to have less
cardiovascular problems
but it binds very good to sigmar 1 and
sigma 2 which are the factors that we
want to target
so we think that pv-22 could be a better
compound than hydroxychloroquine
and actually just look for yes antiviral
activity of the compound
it has a it has a better antiviral
activity a hydroxychloroquine so it's
improved something like 20 times
in terms of inhibitory concentration 90
when you compare both of them
the other set of compounds that we found
are these translational inhibitors so
typhin is one of them that we are now
moving into animal models
it has a target one factor involved in
translation
which is e i f 4a
um the advantage is that has been
already in clinical studies for
in phase 1 2 studies for cancer it has a
very reasonable ic90 around 154
nanomolar so sub micromolar
and it has also a relatively good
selective index
it looks like there is some cytotoxicity
you see this discontinuous line going
from 100
to around 50 but it stays at fifty
percent
it means that the compound is not
cytotoxic
but it's cytostatic meaning uh because
these are growing cells
when you put the compound into the media
the cells stop growing
so 48 hours later you look to what is
100
of cells in the case of the cells
without compound
the cells have duplicated the cells with
compound they don't grow well
they have not duplicated and they look
like you have 50 percent less
cells which is what the cytotoxic the
assay measures the number of life cells
so this reduction to 50 is not due to
killing of the cells it's just
due to inhibition of the growth of these
cells
which that means that hopefully will be
tolerable
um in vivo um
now a a similar compound to uh
um to this um
um thin is
uh this other compound which is a plated
epsilon so pitodepsin is a compound that
has that is targeted in this factor e
if1a
is a compound that has been developed by
a pharmaceutical company
pharma mar as an inhibitor of myeloma
and is approved for treatment of myeloma
in a couple of countries
and this is one of the compounds that is
more effective that we have seen so you
see here
an ic90 of uh close to one nanomolar
uh which is improved even versus the uh
ic90 of rendezvous
and rendessive is better in human cells
but in human cells
uh this in in monkey cells in human
cells from decibel has
in 1990 of around 10 nanomolar and
plutidepsin has a 1990 efferent one in
one nanomolar so much better inhibitor
than redness
and this is also looking for the
activity of this
factor in human cells not in monkey
cells and is
again it has 1990 that is sub nanomolar
so it seems to be a very good inhibitory
is one that is now being used
in clinical trials phase one clinical
trials in
in spain as well as some happiness it
also in korea
and we are starting also to be using in
animal models to see how good this
is is working so this is what we have
obtained from uh
from the um interactum
by edition we have conducted more
screens also based on
systems biology so here the next screen
that we conducted
also in collaboration with nevan krogan
is based on looking to the
phospho proteome in virus infected cells
so what is the phosphor proteome in
virus-infected cells
these are proteins that change
phosphorylation horse proteins that
change phosphorylation
during infection with the virus but
again we speculate
that if they change phosphorylation is
they are going to make an
impact in viral replication either
because they inhibit viral replication
or because that's something that the
virus wants
and then um increase vowel replication
and knowing the the proteins that become
phosphorylated during valid infection we
can also predict
what kinases are the most likely that
are participating in these
phosphorylation events
and now what we are going to target are
now this predicted kindnesses
that are predicted to phosphorylate
those proteins that become
phosphorylated invalid infection
we're going to target these horse
kinases with some non-inhibitors
okay so here are some non-inhibitors
from some of the kinesis that we
identified have been activated during
value infection
and then this one example apili mode is
one inhibitor of this kinase pik5
and has a very good level of inhibition
of our replication
dynasty clip is an inhibitor of city
case which has some of the ones that
also identified that they have been
activated during bioreplication again is
a good inhibitor of our publication
we have also inhibitors of map kinases
that we also identified
as activated during viral replication
that seems to be good inhibitors
of our replication and also in in one of
these
in the h panel if you treat cells with
an srna meaning you
down modulate this particular kinase you
also make an impact in bioreplication so
either
that modulation the kinase by srna or by
an inhibitor of these kinases
is able to inhibit our application so
and the last
um kinase inhibitor that i'm going to
saw
is um this one's silmitazer tip
that inhibit gas in kindness ii that
is interesting because it's not only
activated in viral infection but it's
also known to interact with them protein
of the virus so we think that has
multiple
sites of evidence that that is required
for our replication and in fact
it has also a relatively good ic50
around a 2.3 micromolar
okay but some of our studies have been
done not with these omics approaches but
something else are predicting from the
structural studies
so this is the case for example of a
study that we have conducted together
with uh kushbubafna and gaitano
monteglioni at the rensselaer
polytechnic institute announcing
collaboration with bob crook
at university of texas of austin in
which they have compared the crystal
structure
of the hepatitis c virus protease and
the
m-pro which is a protease that is
encoded by
saskanovirus2 and that is required for
our replication
and even though they belong to different
class of protests they have a very
similar active site
so we predicted that some of the
inhibitors of
uh hep-c protease that have been used
for treatment of hep-c infections will
also inhibit
such chronovirus two main proteins and
then we tested that in antibiotics again
chris white and lisa marine and lena
corderon romel now in my lab
and we found that even though they have
ic90s that are around
20 micromolar many of the hepatitis c
virus inhibitors like boss previa
or grasoprevia are able also to inhibit
a sarcoma virus to replication this is
another example with fanny preview
and sim preview i just show you the ones
that are working we found that some
others are not working but these at
least are working
and interestingly one of the interesting
things even though these are inhibitory
at macro uh macromolar concentrations if
you use
in combination with mendes severe now
you can use
less amount of these in order to inhibit
efficiently so that means that this
protease inhibitors in this case
grasoprevia
is synergizing with trend severe
in terms of inhibition of our
replication and this one can be seen in
what is called an isoball
uh drug graphic which is here so on in
which
you see you put the concentration of
rendessive
at ic90 the concentration of graso
previewed at ic90
and one giving one constant on the other
and the other variable you put both
together
they are more efficient when you put
them both together inhibited via
replication that separately
and so in theory if you use combination
therapy you are going to get
a better inhibition of our replication
that if you use just
single setup and this makes sense
because rendessive
is an inhibitor of virus rna replication
that means that it's going to be less
virus rna
and if there's less virus rna there is
also going to be
less protease present in in espresso in
the cell
so you're going to require so less of an
inhibitor of the viral protease
for uh inhibiting so it makes sense that
inhibitions of rna polymerase like when
deserving synergize
with inhibitors of the protease of the
virus
okay so i'm going to finish here
and i told you summary of what we have
been doing
and again this is an example of what my
lab has been doing but many of the labs
have been also conducting
similar screen assets so it's very very
interesting to see that some of these
inhibitors
are now coming in clinical trials first
of all the sars chronovirus to interact
on
phosphoprotein provides with rational
therapeutic targets for drug repurposing
we have identified the inhibitors of
sigma receptors of translational factors
and of protein kinases
as spotted inhibitors such coffee to
replication in vitro
as i've shown you the sum of the acv
protease inhibitors inhibit
susceptibility to
micromolar concentrations and synergize
with rendezvous
but further clinical and technical
studies are warranted
and i think that one important thing is
to consider combined therapies
and i just want to thank my lab
in one picture that we have just before
the pandemic of coffee 19 so that's the
reason why we are here without masks
now we make the same picture we will be
all wearing a mask and doing more social
distancing
and i i want to also acknowledge not
only my lab
but many members of the department of
microbiology of
investigators in mount sinai other
collaborators i mentioned nevan and
kevin o'brien
and this bastard some of the patients
that we have been
studying although i have not saw here in
the data
with patients but with this also some
studies that we do and obviously we are
very grateful to
uh patients that give us samples for us
to study
a pathogenesis of saskari 2 and then
funding from niid
from dod from darpa from some
philanthropic
donations like from opp or the jbp
so thanks a lot and i stopped here